all right kings and queens of las vegas
and beyond your throne
awaits at the boulevard mall where you
can have one of the most unique dining
experiences
in town so put your crowns on and check
this out channel your primal instincts
and get ready for a dining experience
off the strip
and into the medieval times we wanted to
bring
uh something different to vegas
and that's exactly what primal
steakhouse is something different
and everything but tamed you're going to
see
dim lighting with medieval times
theme great music
[Music]
think game of thrones meets las vegas
with unique decor and antiques
hand-picked vintage chairs collected
from around the world
and food drinks and prices to die for
now we face smoked new york steak pork
belly
just to name a few crowd favorites you
can have all the
findings the finesse of the strip not
the prices
flavors all the like you know all you
can expect
from those restaurants the strip you can
find it right here
the finesse and flavors of the strip but
also of chef angel's family
right here we got the black ceviche this
is a guatemalan traditional ceviche i
tried to elevate a little bit of
guatemala
so instead go shrimp i got a scalloped
and two crab legs
and we serve it with the yoga chips
fresh yuca chips that we actually cut it
every day
and now we drink okay eddie we are
eating our medieval steak and now we
need our strong medieval drink right
what are the flavors that go into this
so the flavor profile is gonna be more
sweet but yet strong so we're gonna
start with kettle
peach in horse boston okay we are gonna
put in some apricot brandy
okay so what makes your your signature
cocktail so unique here
i believe it's just a horn that you're
drinking out of because everybody's
going to grab the horn and look at it
and be like well i feel like i should be
sitting on the throne
i am going to add also even pores of
orange juice and cranberry okay
see the scales there and then what i am
going to do is ask you to go ahead and
put in
the dry ice hey
you've got a special rhythm going on
here's the bartender
and then you want to go ahead and pour
that into the top
the dry ice effect very medieval we call
it the viking punch
all right it's ready for me to drink yes
it is i feel like i need a
a good medieval line this is
too much fun at primal i loved it there
thank you so much to primal steakhouse
for sponsoring this segment check out
the steakhouse at boulevard mall for
more information or to make your
reservation just call
702-620-5103
or visit primalsteakhouse.com